le yémen s'effondre en silence
malgré ses larmes et ses cris de bébés
affamés dans certaines régions du pays
un enfant sur cinq de moins de cinq ans
souffrent de malnutrition aiguë avec
même des records atteints dans le sud du
yémen it une alerte lancée fin octobre
par les fonds des nations unies pour
l'enfance le yémen souffrent du problème
de la malnutrition à cause de la guerre
qui fait rage dans le pays depuis plus
de sept ans le problème de la sécurité
alimentaire est aujourd'hui l'une des
principales raisons pour lesquelles les
enfants sont amenés râblât la
malnutrition ainsi que les femmes
enceintes et allaitant des mers
complètement désemparé et obligé parfois
d'emmener leurs enfants dans des
hôpitaux pour une alimentation par sonde
[Musique]
est très malade et j'ai dû vendre une
bonbonne de gaz pour la transporter à
l'hôpital
son père n'a pas de travail mon enfant
est dans cet état à cause du manque de
nourriture et on n'a rien parce qu'on ne
peut pas travailler et il n'y a aucune
solution pour le moment pas pareil star
et maman chérie am alive venir pour
prendre soin de la petite rafah la
famille peut compter sur une équipe
médicale qui travaillent sans relâche et
fait souvent face à un manque colossal
de moyens de tous les cas que nous
traitons environ 25 à 30 des cas de
malnutrition et à bas coût avec
malheureusement des indications parfois
rafa très vert
escalade du conflit déclin économique
sans compter les impacts dévastateurs de
la pandémie de qu'ovide 19 le yémen fait
face à la pire crise humanitaire au
monde pour l'unicef les programmes de
traitement de la malnutrition sont
également menacés si des fonds
supplémentaires ne sont pas reçus
rapidement pour pouvoir renforcer
d'urgence et programme les nations unies
disent avoir besoin de plus de 50
millions de dollars
et le temps presse au yémen puisque près
de cent mille enfants de moins de 5 ans
risque actuellement de mourir de
malnutrition aiguë sévère